من القاهره تنضم الينا الفنانه هدى الفهد
هدى صبحك الله بالخير صباح الخير
اهلين صبحك الله بالنور يا هلا ومرحبا ليش
الا قلبي انا ما راح اسالك بقيه الاسئله
ليش الا قلبي
ليش الا قلبي الا قلبي اكثر اغنيه
بالالبوم على فكره تعني لي كثير
لانها من الى يعني
من الحان التوزيع
فكرتي كانت وسلامه
الله يسلمك
هناك ايضا اغنيه الحيله اللي شفنا هيك
الفيديو كليب جزء من الفيديو كليب لالها
لاحظت انه ستايل الفيديو كليب هيك كانه
رتره قديم بفتره الخمسينيات او قبل هيك
ستايل الاستعراض القديم هاي كانت كانت
فكرتك ايضا
وليش
انا والمخرج الصراحه اتناقشنا فيها يعني
غالبا
المخرج حسن غدار
اقترح انه
[موسيقى]
انه تكون طريقه التصوير الكليبات كلها
قديمه فكل الاغاني راح تكون يعني بالوقت
الحالي
عشان يمكن نوضح الموضوع اكثر بالحيله يمكن
في الاغاني اللي قبلها ما وصلت للناس طيب
قبل لا اسالك شربتي قهوتك
هدى شربت قهوتك
طب ايش راح تسمعينا طالما شربت القهوه
لازم نسمع قبل ما اسالك
وش راح اسمعكم مقطع ناخذ من الحيله يلا
ممكن الحيله ممكن اللي تبينه
الحيله ده اللي حيلتي
الحيله ده حل بايدي ضفرتي
الحيله ده
فتحلو ورد خدي ومن قدي صغره لليله عندي
الليله عندي يلا طب هدى هني انا ودي اسالك
الفن او الجانب الطلبي في الاغنيه ولا
اللي ما هو يعرف اليوم بالاغاني السريعه
الشبابيه ايهما اقرب هدى وين تلاقي نفسها
ولا ما تحبين يحسبونك على لون
لا الصراحه يعني يمكن الاجابه هذه تلقاها
بالبومي لانك متنوع ما كنت منحصره بلون
معين يعني على ما يقولون رضيت كل الاذواق
يعني كل احد لقى ذوقه
ولهذا السبب اخترتي على الاقل
وانا ضد الواحد ينحصر طيب وعلى هذا الاساس
اخترتي انه اغنيه الحيره تكون باللهجه
المصريه ولا في سبب اخر لذلك
صحيح
لا صحيح كتنوع طيب يعني حلو الفنان يكون
مختلف ويغني كذا لهجه اكيد طبعا ويوصل لكل
اكيد لازم
انا انا طماع ودي اسمع
يعني يمكن انا اول اول اغنيه نزلت فيها
كانت من البدايه عراقيه
حلو خلينا نسمع كثير حبوها العالم
بدنا اغنيه باللهجه يا اما سعوديه يا اما
العراقيه اذا هيك شفتي شلون
يلا قولي العراقيه
من البدايه اصلا غلط مفروض اجرب ايدي خط
فوق الجرح ملح حط لصار بيل شفتها من
البدايه اصلا غلط
مفروض اجرب ايدي خط فوق الجرح ملحه نحط لا
صار بيا اللي شفته
دق قلبي
حالفتنا
ليجيبت اسمي على لسانه صرت انا اكبر ناس
تعبانه
يا عمي خلها سكته
هدى لا تحطين الميكروفون تكفون بايدك خلي
الميكروفون وخلني اسالك عند الا قلبي ابي
اسمعها ولو مقطع صغير يلا
ما ادري ايش كثر باقي لنا هوا
انت ما تبون لا لا والله بنسولف بس بدنا
نسمع يعني صوتك بسم الله ما شاء الله
فبالتالي نسمع ونسولف
ولا لا خلاص خليها بعد شوي اليوم هدى وين
تلاقي نفسك انه الفنانات السعوديات خلال
هذه الثوره الثقافيه في السعوديه اللي
قاعده تصير التقدم الثقافي والغنائي الفني
هدى وين تلاقي نفسها
وين الاقي نفسي وين تلاقين هل هل تعتقدين
انه اليوم الفنانات السعوديات حاضرات بشده
وبكثافه
الصراحه الفرصه موجوده
وفي في تواجد
يعني في في تواجد كثير حلو
يعني
يعني مش يعني مو من فتره قليله يعني من
اول ما بدا موسم الرياض بدا ظهور الفنانات
السعوديات طيب وانت هدى كمان شاركتي في
الفتره الاخيره بجوله في المملكه وشاركتي
فيه حفل في جازان كيف بتقيمي هاي الجوله
بشكل عام المشهد الفني الغنائي في
السعوديه كمان من وجهه نظرك
شوفي بصراحه يعني انا اشوفها فرصه كثير
حلوه انه
اول شيء تتعرف على على الجمهور بكل مدينه
تزورها
هذه تعطيك فرصه ان الناس تعرفك اكثر
يعني حتى اساسا هذه كانوا يسوونها بامريكا
اول ما يطلع باند
وينزلون البوم جديد يسوون تور على كل
الستيت
عشان الناس تتعرف عليهم اكثر
فهي نفس الفكره فهذا الحلو فيها انه انت
قاعد تزور مدن
تواجدك يصير بشكل اكبر والناس تعرفك اكثر
عارفينه على قلبك يا عبر اغنيه هلا قلبي
لانه وقت
برنامجنا دقيقه
باجي دقيقه عندنا الا قلبي بسرعه صوتك
بمسك المايك كذا المره الجايه كل الوقت
قلبي لا تحاول تقنعه
اسمع صوتي
مو قاعد اسمع صوتي
يا هدى سامعينك
الا قلبي لا تحاول تقنعه
خذ معك جرحك وسافر به بعيد
وفر شعورك لغيري يسمعك
ما ابيلك عذر لو ابقى وحيد
حبك اللي ضاع عمري اتباع ما ترك لشيخ
خليني سعيد في ملامح وجهي ذكرى موجعه عندي
مالك شي يشفعلك اكيد
هدى الفهد قلبه ابيض وسامحي يعني سامحيني
على ايضا سرعه هذا اللقاء وطلبنا منه
اشتقنا منك ثقلنا عليك وطلبنا منك وايد
اغاني لكن شكرا جزيلا لهدى الفهد الفنانه
السعوديه من القاهره كانت معنا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات